apple just threw a massive curve ball
our way with the ipad air 5 because they
gave it something that basically nobody
was expecting the m1 chip yes the same
industry changing m1 chip that comes in
apple's 1300 macbook pro is now packed
into the brand new 600 ipad air making
it the absolute cheapest way to get the
m1 chip even cheaper than the m1 mac
mini which doesn't even come with the
display and trust me we were all blown
away last year when apple stuck the m1
into the ipad pro but them now throwing
it into the ipad air 5 made me almost
jump out of my chair during the event
because i just couldn't believe it and
now the question that's on everyone's
mind is if the ipad air 5 is now a much
better value than the ipad pro since you
get the same chip for 200 less cash and
that's exactly what i'm gonna do in this
video by laying out all the differences
and explaining my point of view on which
ipad you should be buying but before i
get into all of those little differences
there is a question on my mind that has
been really bothering me so let me go
ahead and try to give you an answer for
what the heck apple was thinking by
throwing the m1 chip into this new ipad
air as you probably already know the
ipad lineup was even more messed up
before apple's march event because late
last year they updated the ipad mini 6
with a bunch of new features while not
touching the ipad air 4 at all and the
number one thing that put the lineup out
of whack was the fact that the ipad mini
6 came with apple's latest a15 chip
while the ipad air was still stuck with
the a14 while also being a hundred
dollars more expensive so for those who
wanted to have the larger 10.9 inch
display they would have to pay a hundred
dollars more just to lose performance
with the air which made no sense at all
so coming up to the march 8th peak
performance event we were all expecting
the ipad air to get the a15 bionic chip
so that it made sense within the full
ipad lineup but the problem with that
idea is that it would just be playing
catch up to the ipad mini which already
had the a15 and all of the other cool
features like the 12 megapixel ultrawide
selfie camera and the optional 5g
cellular support and in reality we
ourselves were expecting a pretty boring
update to the ipad air so one of the
reasons i think apple tossed in the m1
chip instead was to basically blow
everyone away and get some real
attention back on the ipad air again
making it actually worth the 600 price
tag because for the last year even
before the ipad mini 6 was released the
ipad air just hasn't really been worth
it because it was in a really weird spot
where paying an extra 200 for the 11
inch ipad pro for 800
made so much more sense because of the
sheer number of extra features so we
literally told you guys to either buy
one of the lower end ipads like the 10.2
inch budget model or go straight for the
800 ipad pro but now for the first time
in over a year the ipad air finally
makes sense and it actually feels like a
substantial upgrade over the ipad mini 6
which is exactly what apple wants they
want to make each ipad in the lineup
tempting so that you'll want to spend
just a little bit more money but that
right there has become the new problem
the ipad air gets the m1 ship for only
600
which was a huge shock to me so the big
question is why in the world would
anybody pay the extra 200 for the 11
inch ipad pro and if they did what
exactly would they be getting for that
extra cash well for starters the one
drawbacks of the ipad air is that it
only comes with 64 gigs of storage
compared to the ipad pro which starts
with
128 gigs and if you did want to upgrade
the storage on the air you've got to
spend
750 dollars total literally putting you
right into ipad pro territory but in
terms of the actual feature and spec
differences you'll be surprised by just
how much extra you get with the ipad pro
first of all even though the ipad air
supports optional 5g it does not come
with millimeter wave 5g like the ipad
pro does and even though the ipad air
comes with the same m1 chip the ipad pro
actually gets a full on thunderbolt 3
slash
4 port which supports a bunch of other
thunderbolt devices as well as transfer
speeds up to 40 gigabits per second
compared to only 10 with the ipad air 5.
and even though the ipad air comes with
the same four speaker grilles it
actually only comes with two speakers
one on the top and one on the bottom
while the ipad pro comes with an
absolutely incredible quad speaker
system which is something that's really
important to me and this four speaker
system was one of the things that was
rumored to come on the ipad air but we
unfortunately did not get it and
speaking of rumors that didn't come true
it was said that the ipad air would come
with a new dual camera system on the
back with a wide camera and an ultra
wide camera like on the ipad pro but we
didn't get that either which was very
disappointing but it looks like apple
decided to just toss in the m1 chip for
the wow factor while keeping the same
camera design which is definitely the
cheaper option for apple and then on top
of the ipad pro getting the dual cameras
it also gets a flash and the lidar
scanner which can be used for games 3d
scanning and augmented reality apps and
going further the ipad pro comes with
five studio quality microphones while
the air only gets two microphones and if
you think that's already a long list of
differences those were actually the ones
that don't really matter that much so
now let's get into the two major
differences the ipad pro comes with
apple's face id system which means that
it unlocks automatically without you
having to do anything but simply swiping
up on the display but with the ipad air
you've got to use the touch id power
button which i personally find annoying
because you've got to reach for that
sensor which isn't nearly as reliable as
face id but the absolute biggest deal is
the fact that the ipad pro has a much
better display and this right here is a
game changer first of all the 11 ipad
pro display has thinner bezels while
also being brighter with 600 nits of
brightness compared to 500 on the air
but the best part of all is that the
ipad pro comes with 120hz pro motion
technology which means that the display
refreshes at up to 120 hertz compared to
60 on the air giving you a super smooth
display experience where everything just
feels super snappy with less motion blur
which can make it easier to read while
scrolling and overall much more
enjoyable and in my opinion the 120hz
promotion feature is worth 200 dollars
more alone
even if everything else between the air
and the pro was identical and if you
don't believe me let me explain why yes
the m1 chip sounds amazing for the ipad
air but it is 100 percent
overkill for the 60 hertz display
because it really doesn't help it feel
any more snappy compared to the old a14
chip in the last ipad air which was also
very fast and if you're someone who
wants to play games on your ipad the m1
chip isn't really going to change
anything because the old a14 could run
almost every game at a perfectly solid
60 fps which matches the ipad air's 60
hertz display so the m1 ship really
isn't giving you an advantage at all and
then on the other hand there are a lot
of games that now support 120 fps on the
ipad pro like league of legends wild
rift and even gentian impact and the m1
gives you just enough performance to
take advantage of the 120 hertz display
making it the best gaming tablet in the
world since even tablets like the brand
new samsung galaxy tab s8 ultra don't
support 120fps in many games so the fact
that the new ipad air still has a
regular 60hz display basically ruins the
entire point of apple throwing in the m1
chip especially since you don't even get
the thunderbolt port so with all that
said let me give you guys my
recommendations if you actually care
about being able to put the m1 chip to
use or if you already own an iphone 13
pro then absolutely spend the extra 200
because you're getting the 120 hertz
display the extra storage the
thunderbolt port the face id system the
quad speakers and much more but if you
just want a nice and fresh modern
looking ipad to use features like the
new 12 megapixel ultra wide selfie
camera with center stage support and you
care more about saving two hundred
dollars than getting a bunch of extra
premium features then simply stick with
this ipad air so there you go hopefully
you guys enjoy this comparison and if
you did go ahead and click the circle
above to subscribe for our hands-on full
comparison between these two ipads when
we get it in our hands and definitely
check out our mac studio coverage right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video